I always like being casual positive day
one that doesn't mean I need to have
crazy margins they want but I want to be
casual positives they want so that this
thing isn't feeding off me it's feeding
on itself and then I can double down on
feeding as much of that profit as
possible as reinvestment in
infrastructure or media to grow the
business and I do it faster that way
rather than pocketing it because when
you're pocketing the cash from the
business it means that you feel like you
will get a better risk-adjusted return
outside of the business and so if you
leave the money in the business then it
means that you feel like you will get a
better risk of just a return I have
advised many small business owners to
take cash out of the business because it
teaches them how to make a profit like
not a story of profit someday but
actually do that because when I had my
six gyms I reinvested the whole way
through and then I lost them all so I
probably would have taken more money
during that period of time and I might
not have gone as fast now that I no
longer need that from a risk basis me
taking the money out and putting in the
s p versus me taking the money out and
putting in acquisition.com and how that
will compound I believe will
dramatically outperform the market